anonymous chatting on the internet isn't
just for shadowy criminal hackers and
government operatives from journalists
to congressmen learning how to adjust
the privacy of our digital communication
is becoming an ever more important skill
to know when Edward Snowden first
reached out to journalist Glenn
Greenwald he insisted on only using
encrypted communications Greenwald's
lack of technical skills nearly cost him
the story of the century but where the
colleagues helped Greenwald learned how
to use encrypted chat servers a far more
efficient and secure method than even
encrypted emails or text messages
browsing and communicating on the
internet anonymously is difficult
time-consuming and painstaking one weak
link or careless trace of metadata can
expose your identity to the world but
that doesn't mean you need a master's
degree in computer science to avoid the
prying eyes of the NSA in five easy
steps recent TV shows you the basics of
how to chat anonymously online step one
download the tor browser
unlike other web browsers that store
your personal information and browsing
history for corporate advertisers and
government subpoenas tor is completely
decentralized the user driven free
software reroutes your information
through a network of thousands of
computers worldwide to hide the users
identity now known publicly through
Snowden's revelations the five eyes the
Anglophone allies who frequently
collaborate as the greatest global
spying behemoth ever known have admitted
being unable to directly D anonymize any
specific tor user and although they've
been able to do not eyes a few random
tor users they still can't do it on
demand from this point on for the
purposes of maintaining anonymity you
should always be using the tor browser
when downloading subsequent applications
and creating personal accounts
associated with those applications step
to using off-the-record chat servers
like tor is for web browsers jabber chat
servers are decentralized and unlike
mainstream chat services jabber doesn't
require you to enter any verifiable
personal information to create an
account the encryption protocol known as
off-the-record or ot are allows both
sides of a chat to be encrypted there
are literally hundreds of jabber servers
around the world available to use once
you've selected a jabber server create
an account but remember only use a
server that lets you sign up using the
Tor brow
when creating a username and password
use random number and letter
combinations for each account and never
use the same name or password twice also
be sure to write down this information
and keep it in a safe place
uploading this information to an
insecure cloud-based server like Dropbox
or Evernote or god forbid email put your
security at needless risk and
jeopardizes your anonymity step 3
download a DM for Mac users download a
DM using tor and make sure to keep your
tor browser open when using Adium to
maintain connectivity there are programs
specifically for windows but for this
lesson we'll stick with mac OSX select a
diems dropdown box then choose
preferences select the accounts tab then
click the plus sign to add a new account
select XMPP jabber I know it's getting a
little detailed now but stick with me
the next steps ensure that a DM will
work only using tor switch to the proxy
tab click connect using proxy then
choose sock s5 type 127.0.0.1 into the
server field create a new username and
password you see where it says port type
9 1 5 0 there go to the privacy tab and
where it says encryption switch it to
force encryption and refuse plain text
go to options and in the resource box
delete your computer's name and type
anonymous then check require SSL TLS go
back to account and type in your jabber
ID which were created in step 2 your ID
is comprised of the jabber username you
created in step 2 followed by an @ sign
and finally the jabber server you chose
enter your password
finally to test your accounts connection
switch your status to available step 4
creating encryption keys and
fingerprints you'll need a key to unlock
encrypted messages to create a key click
adium choose preferences after that go
to advanced and click encryption select
your account and click generate which
will create your encryption key and
fingerprint
to have an encrypted chat a person needs
to know your jabber username server and
your fingerprint exchanged fingerprints
over another communication channel
step 5 to verify contacts add a person's
jabber ID remember this is your user
name plus an @ sign plus the jabber
server to your contacts if the contact
is online you will only be able to see
them if they have authorized your
contact request once they have you can
authorize them back finally you can
click on the contact and begin chatting
though you've sent a message you will
only be certain your chat is secure if
the fingerprints match compare them in
the OTR fingerprint verification box
which should pop up after the first
message has been sent if every single
character matches you can trust this
contact and that's it happy anonymous
chatting
you